hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen today I
am watching home alone - I like the
first one so much I just thought I'd
continue it on yeah I watched home loan
one for the first time ever last
Christmas with mr. Jim J Roz and we had
unpopular opinions about it I am going
to check out the second one to see if it
got any better if it has any redeeming
qualities if it's funny I think it
supposed to be a comedy pretty sure oh
who knows like maybe you'll like it more
than the first
[Music]
I didn't obviously this was made because
the first one did so well and I'm so
glad the first one did well I think I
missed the boat on it I needed to see it
when I was younger I didn't and I just
missed the boat you can't watch home
alone or home alone - at 26 and be like
that is a fine ass piece of cinematic
gold maybe you can if you can that's
awesome I I cannot look I missed it
that's just not for me anymore I can't
enjoy it any longer
so home alone - lost in New York they
made it because the first one did well
and and they wanted to make more money
off of it and the coley-cole kid was
popular and I understand the reasoning
behind making it but the script was so
lazy and it was just all the same jokes
jokes rehashed
and it just felt like super dumb like so
dumb I go very much back and forth with
liking and the character of Kevin Coley
Culkin's character in in this film on
the last film he's this little jerk like
his little old man jerk who's super
entitled and like spends all of his
family's vacation money on this lavish
trip to New York but then also there's
certain points where I feel bad for him
so it starts off and Kevin is like why
are we all gonna go to Florida for
Christmas they don't even have Christmas
trees and his mom is like what is it
with you and Christmas trees and it's
like I don't know mom I'm ten god oh how
hilariously wake up late like last time
we did it again Oh Kevin gets on the
wrong flight what extreme high jinks is
oh no my family's in Florida and I'm in
New York
oh my family's in Florida and I'm in New
York he's not a good actor and I there
was like this crazy crazy around him
when the first one came out and everyone
was like oh my god with all the smoke
all along and he's creepy and his lips
are weird I'm sorry I should not be
child shaving I just don't see the
appeal person though he's exploring all
of New York and I bids New York public
transit is no joke and he's just like
zooming off around like good for him
she's pretty competent
so then the parents inevitably find out
that kevin is missing and it's so over
acted in such a weird way the mom finds
out at the airport in Florida someone's
like Kevin's not here and she's like and
then she passes out like what the was
that mom then it's just it's the script
because the parents are telling this cop
that they lost Kevin and they're like
well actually we've done this before
funny thing though we've never lost the
luggage and knock on wood
I'm sorry above you then the same bad
guys are there oh what a coincidence
then Kevin goes to the Plaza Hotel and
there are no remarkable actors or points
no camps that I wish to address
another weird line reading cuckoo legal
kid and man sometimes I get into mister
we all do
I wrote Lowell tim curry is lovely
Rob Schneider dot dot dot I do have a
lot of questions about this though like
why does tim curry care so much about
Kevin
he's like find out everything you can
about that digital boy like to the point
where we go in and he's showering also
how is Kevin so good at making fake
people and like making dummies that
scare off adults it is impressive and I
love how they built it up to kids listen
I was saying like I should have seen
this as a kid I think I would have
really enjoyed all of the traps that he
sets and like all of the like fake
people to like I thought what a dream as
a kid to see that how fun definitely but
that's a 26 year old I'm just like how
were you doing that Kevin how the
meanwhile the criminals are there ice
skating little brat keV keV takes
himself through a toy store to spend all
his family's vacation money dick an hour
and it feels like it should be wrapping
up by now
Oh JK they have to have the sad portion
of the plot pigeon lady Hey Arnold a way
better so after the whole pigeon lady
plot which is supposed to be sad same as
like the old crotchety neighbor and the
first one the old man it's supposed to
be sad but it's just not earned at all
and I know Doug and Rob are so upset
that I said that about the first one but
it just doesn't feel and at all it feels
like it's just like well we got to put
something cheesy and corny and sad in
here so that like he looks like not a
complete jerk this like 10 year old
doesn't look like a total asshole so
here we go that's what it feels like at
the 26 year old Washington for the first
time I'm sure it's a kid watching it we
finally get to the part that is at least
it's fun to watch all of the traps that
Kevin has set for the two crooks at
least some physical violence just comes
through and saves the day he's reunited
with his mother reunited with the family
and the movie ends with this rich family
just getting a ton of free gifts ah
Christmas it's just a cheesy and
predictable and annoying like at the
very very end Kevin goes out and he goes
to the the dub lady the the pigeon lady
and he's like I'll never forget you
here's a Turtledove to remember me by
and it's like cool man you're not
helping her at all not that like a
ten-year-old should like be responsible
for helping an adult but it just sets it
up to where like he's like he should be
earning a Nobel Peace Prize for what
he's doing for this pigeon lady and it's
like nah man Rob Schneider is a bellhop
rated pg-13
I predict that you'll love Tim Korea but
that's kind of cheating because everyone
loves Tim Curry Tim Curry was the saving
grace of this film and he wasn't even in
a good role like the role sucked he had
to star next to Rob Schneider and he was
still excellent sometimes Tim Curry is
the greatest gift that rooftop scene
will have you pissing in laughter and
you'll be wondering if
just gave this guy permanent brain
damage I was wondering if Kevin gave the
guy permanent brain damage but I will
say that nothing about one or two for
home alone maybe piss and laughter
you're gonna point out all the
similarities to the first movie look at
similarity
it was the same goddamn Turtledove scene
the fields but did you watch as a kid
though cuz I don't think watching it for
the first time as an adult will give you
those few I really don't because I love
feeling things and Phil it's like my
favorite thing I will find feels in any
movie but I did not it's I did
not hit her I did not
oh hi turtle about next week I was gonna
be watching screwed it was one that was
on my list for last year and I just
never got to it thank you guys so much
for watching I've got a really fun month
lined up after this as well so keep
tuning in I really think that's all I
need to talk about there isn't really
anything else I need to address other
than if you see a kid wandering around
alone in New York in a hotel that you
own me check
why the kid is there and be a better
actor
okay well see ah my sweet bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you